all right so by popular demand we are
doing Steven universe a lot of people
dance this time I thought we were doing
arrow
no no Steven universe not the flash uh
all right Stevens you we're doing our
gonna be even do even Steven's universe
it's just I love her Shia LaBeouf to go
back just like three straight like just
force maybe so much the green screen
like quit sitting are we sure that's not
shot he's way too happy and positive
this is our first episode laser light
cabin you wanna start ah well billions
of years ago the earth was a molten mass
as if we're all we know maybe the story
does start off like that don't this okay
so as far as I can tell I'm gonna
preface this with I know nothing about
this show apart from the fact that I saw
literally a handful of episodes that I
mean three or four somewhere in the
middle and they're only 15 minutes each
I said set what we did Jesse just
something somewhere in the middle so I
don't know anybody's names I don't know
jack squat I'm sure I know correct
though I am not telling you now like I
would rather go into a show blind like
most people do when their start up from
the beginning so I don't know jack-shit
about Steven universe I'm not sure how
much more we watching this well that's
why I'm gonna get it because I'm not
going to be mentioning a whole bunch of
names yet because I don't know them are
from Steven so yeah don't flip the fuck
out but as far as I can tell there's
this kind of roly-poly kid named Steven
who looks kind of like Jay Sherman's son
from the Crypt
oh yeah across a little bit of
even-steven Shia LeBouf with sort of a
Mable shirt is the only way I can
describe it from gravity falls
he is hanging out with three women of
indeterminate age but they seem to be
definitely grown adults of various
different body types and races and sizes
and what-have-you who all seem very
friendly when they discovered there is a
giant death eye death star thing coming
down from the sky and they're like oh my
god see the other news I think about
this and so Stevens like I don't know
we're gonna do but it had something to
do with imma go find my dad and so he
finds his dad who looks kind of like
Carl's cousin uh from Aqua Teen Hunger
Force yeah I almost expect him to settle
like Oh our way through there definitely
is a personality maybe a little bit of a
loser yeah but you know not the only
that same personality definitely likes
to get sunburned so uh maybe it is in
this case literally a redneck
um and Steven explains to him that yeah
there's all this shit that's gonna fall
from the sky with vines in Wenzhou and
he's like well we can look in my was it
the garage of the basement storage
storage room you're look at my storage
room and see if we can find anything so
he goes searching in the storage room
and my favorite line in the hole she was
like wow it's like a dead museum in here
it was finding only taken by the line -
because I was just like yes a really
good luck the only thing is I was
thinking about I'm like what great epic
just what a great image what a great way
to say that now whenever I like go
through my dad's Junkers yeah I'm good
things I'm using yeah yeah go would like
if we need to pick stuff up out of the
crawlspace you sold some old props down
there but he's got a whole bunch of his
stuff um and I'm just gonna quads I
could did you see ya know I love that
pine - um so eventually he finds this
and they have like this conversation
where he reveals that what we already
know he's his father but he reveals that
at one point there was this magical
woman who must've bonked him and
therefore there came Steven but in order
for this strange union to happen she had
to give up her physical
I couldn't make this up if I tried no I
had to give up her physical form and so
Stephens left I'm assuming the mothers
gone
he accidentally steps on an image of the
mother she looks very pretty with pink
hair whatever she looks like she could
be related to the other three women who
were on the beach but that's beside the
point at the moment anyway picks up uh
some sort of cannon the type thing
brings it back meanwhile they've been
launching the the biggest girl into the
eye death I again and again and she
keeps watching it back I'm sure in the
background the zambese like a splash
bird splash yes yes okay uh but anyway
so he has this he and his dad Steven and
his dad I have this thing about um you
you know what happens to really they
said it like five times together why why
telling this whole fucking story from
the beginning and you're gonna yell at
me about that you say it that whenever I
did my recaps on adventure time I got
all the names all the characters every
little element totally right you sent me
into his life they knew we were coming
they have the little briefing the
envelope envelope is in the oven okay
what was it then cuz I'm remembering of
everything story for you cuz you don't
remember jack shit if every pork chop
was perfect we wouldn't have hot dogs
exactly says that thing turns out that
they're trying to rub Stephen up against
the cannon because Stephen has some
magic jam on him or something that belly
button I think yeah in his belly button
um because he's just like the Japanese
super powerful magic kids he's just one
of those magic boys no trolls from the
90s mirtha yeah I have mom and he's the
son of semantical woman so they're all
born with gems I guess in their belly I
don't know uh so the rubber against the
cannon and that was weird
but finally they say the bozo go again
finally they say okay
contacts make a gif or something fucking
ages I'm doing this for you yeah yeah
you're good for it activates the cannon
which blows up the death I um and so
therefore the dad's catchphrase
activates a cannon which means that I'm
assuming the mother may have had
something to do with that that she has
murdered or something and ever is like
oh and the end everything worked out the
death is destroyed and everything goes
relatively back to normal except for Dan
Stephen who have to go fish their
mystery vehicle mystery van out of the
ocean fair well done Edmund I use my
bladder coach did I miss anything boy
was the part about the pork chop but
yeah but I was there to save you from
that um no this is a dick much like
adventure time this show starts off not
explaining a goddamn thing just starts
off right in the middle
um as I'm entirely true once I found out
that his mother was a magical woman who
bonked his dad a lot made sense at least
suddenly I'm like okay good idea this
how these things are connected
no but you know I'll tell you about most
this must follow yesterday now this
isn't a Highland this is like it it
reminds me of animes do this a lot but
yeah even like anime there would be a
little more explaining going on they
would dump you into the middle of a plot
point a story already in progress but
there would be more kind of hilarious
exposition like do you not know and I'm
just taught my ancient family technique
using this riveted and did you not know
that this person is it like it would
somehow be delivered somehow in the
context of the story and then we got a
couple things uh ya know if they were
slipped in so for the most part subtly I
mean a little obvious but to a point
where it's like uh you know if you
didn't tell me this was the first
episode of something I would never guess
since the first episode and yet I
watched the whole thing and couldn't
tear my eyes away um
Aloha but before we go in private I
should say my background with a little I
have
Steven universe's well I've only seen a
handful of episodes um and we'll kind of
get to those when we get to those uh but
um but yes I have some idea that the
bare essentials that there's like these
three I think
alien women who are with yes Steven
universe
they all have gems in them there's some
sort of magical gems they have no idea
yet if they're alien or Cosmo Baker I
think they're an agile like yeah but I
mean but they're whisk even and yeah I
think the mother was either one of them
or was like their leader or something
that's all I got uh and and now there
was the Stephen because Stephen again
has that jewel and they either feel they
have to protect him or he can help
protect them as well I make work off
each other and they're on this place
under at this Beach City um so if that's
about the majority of what I know uh and
I honestly I'm not even sure I would get
all that if I didn't see those episodes
like I'm so wondering how watched I
would be if I if I was dumped in the
middle of this oh yeah I see here's the
thing a part of me uh really respects
the hell out of shows that just start
off almost not explaining a thing they
just dump you right in the middle
because it's really ballsy to do with
his soul against convention and still
more to do in this country it is well
not as much and some of it no I mean
adventure time did the same thing
adventure time didn't explain a thing it
just dumped you right a Melvin episode
could be confused for any other episode
uh and this one kind of does the same
thing I mean it's not something where
it's like Steven he turns around and
reveals himself bed is Steven it doesn't
take it slow I mean it just tosses you
right in uh you know I don't even I'm
Trever we even got all the characters
nay humans in this lab sure they did but
they do not hammer it is not like a
curtain call or an introductory or
anything it's just right in the middle
of it and part of me really respects the
hell out of it but for my adult mind
that finds it hard to follow all of this
stuff up just like I hate this up but I
know it's good uh it's just trying to be
nice the only
it bothers and but that but that's my
issue because I've eleven reason the
only reason it bothers me is because we
have to do these V walks yes meaning
that I'm some reason we blink and we
miss it
the entire net ever be like but but i
but it honestly if I'm just watching
this for my own amusement than that for
doing a V lug I find first episode by me
I would keep watching because I was like
mesmerised I'm like what fuck going on
something better catch was very early
cousin try think if I was if I was a kid
or an eater kid or adult watching this
first episode would I come back to it
and I I'm thinking about so because when
you don't start off the traditional way
with the introductions and stuff I mean
it's like it just automatically confuses
you in confusion usually it's not the
best way to start off a show you want
them to get very quick so you can get
invested how many times have you ever
said okay see well they did let me
finish okay I was gonna say that I
probably not like I need to see the next
one but I probably would tune in again
because a it did start off like that and
that's just so strange and be there was
sort of this even though a lot of chaos
was happening with this is gonna hit the
ground and let the color scheme changes
and everything and the world's gonna end
whatever there's still kind of this
laid-back tone that was kind of charming
and endearing and I don't really see
that much when the end of the world is
going to happen and it's sort of this
even the opening team very laid back
it's our pinellas song like you know
crystal gems a little bit of people very
quiet to do and Chris now is channels my
go like this I'll do that again
yeah oh but yeah it's one of those where
it's like I be I would be a little
curious but not like oh I got to see the
next episode but it is just not enough
and so uniquely designed even by shows
today because we're kind of seeing these
more simplistic designs in these simple
shape but it's a throwback that that is
like what are the colors the colors are
real throw
get the shoes oh sorry she's cut
definitely Oh background layout and yeah
I mean she's definitely 70s but uh it
may be a little like the curly hair in
the star but this is maybe one of those
designs that says gravity falls and that
sort of adventure time and stuff but but
but the color I I see very I read some
anime I saw school anime that a lot of
the havoc with everything else like look
at the rest of it I'm not saying I'm
Lansing look at the lines and stuff and
the colors like that's all 70s and early
when they had their own stylistic you
know they have their own style - but I
when I look at it I see like old-school
70s 80s anime um like no no question
about it what I want even like just the
advertiser the 70s and 80s I mean
couldn't you see this like advertising
like a cassette oh it's all just got all
the colors on that's what I love about I
mean the art design on this show is
amazing well what I was going to say is
that the what I like is that you can see
the silhouette of any of them and know
who they are I like that I really like a
show that can do that a character design
and it also like a book all thrid the
one time the characters five all five
characters so far the other thing I like
are all different ages races and body
types you know this that a lot but not
in an obvious way where it's like
freaking Captain Planet or we're trying
to be like all PC about it like it's not
even mentioned it's just organically
sort of just what you can go over to the
inside I'll have them leave a bigger
impact on you because you can have like
the really big eyes and the big mouths
but you got the the the middle-aged dad
you've got he's sort of rolling lowly
kid she's uh she's like a larger woman
like she's like kind of muscle-bound
this this is she's like waiting yeah you
know it's like literally every in the
heights
- yeah different high tonight like I'm
just like I'm used to a lot of cartoons
like having a generic design and I'm
like they did I like the show they come
in all shapes and sizes
no I don't actually
or interesting to wound up the big vid
exits I should add yeah cuz she's got I
can't quite figure it out yet but uh the
black woman has like a it sounds British
I don't like as long as I say like chip
a kit almost is like it but we don't
talk much in this why do I got this um
like colonial like Island sorta like
either colonial island sort of accent or
like or some sort of like offshoot of
British but we're storm from from x-men
do you remember oh storm I thought she
was African wait what you I forgot those
or early need South Africa I said I
don't write it has a touch of that we
don't know the accent but it's
definitely an accent we know that and uh
but what I see the the colors in this is
what jumps out at me the most because
it's a it's a color scheme I really have
not seen since like you know eighty a
little little good I was last time I saw
any this was watching cartoons when I
was probably four years old for me not
even that I was gonna say like you know
looking in my phonics book you know what
that's like what the the tutor sex with
uh with the sort of the light orange
yeah one light and I'm just like yeah
then look I did with the second he said
that I left it like that it's totally
like the phonics books we had in the
yeah I mean they're kind of like when
you're grown when we run up in
kindergarten stuff like that like these
were kind of like the colors you saw in
all the advertising in the books because
when you print books uh back then you
know Laurie bowling you would a very
simple color yeah you usually have one
color in the whole books you'd have to
do like various you as you go you you
hit yeah right paper your black ink and
then it would be like it would just be
one other color and it was normally like
sort of a yes fellow yeah I was either
and yeah sort of white orange yellow
pink or gray it was always one of those
four color yeah so with that whole scene
where the I've gained closer and goes
that color Tom like this is love very
surreal I guess seen this a long time uh
and very unique even though I guess I'm
kind of more partial to like you know
the colors being a touch more vibrant or
blue tinge or something like that it is
so different it's so jarring and so just
engulfs itself in it I really loved it
um and then when it goes back to serve
the other normal colors uh you know when
the eye leaves it's like you know they
seemed a little bit more vibrant because
of that uh but yeah everything about it
has kind of a I don't usually say it's
like a delightfully faded look like
that's just kind of the tone it's going
for like the lines are very strong the
colors are very strong but it's still
you know what I mean with the yeah but
the shows look little faded the
backgrounds look like they were hand
painted but your neck so yeah but
everything's digital now so I'm
wondering if that was just a style yes
Emmy I want to make it look there were
parts of those backgrounds that looked
water coming to me but I'm sure now
digital's we're at the point where you
can just be a man
ah but it but it had that that faded
watercolor quality to it it was gorgeous
and that's a look at again I remember
for the play
that's the actually the weirdest thing
about the show the thing I love is grunt
and I I'd be very interested I not
knowing anything about this I'll
probably read up on it after we're done
with all the V logs but I'd be
interested know the creator's backstory
on this if they're our age or older and
maybe where do they were younger yeah
and remember this style of artwork
because like I want to talk about like
we talked it's the nostalgia critic
thing like this is really nostalgic
something I'm like flashing you have to
like um it was old I remember like when
the ice cream truck would pass by the
old ads were like the rocket yaps and
stuffing all the colors you know design
that yeah it's it's weird it's giving me
like acid flashbacks when I was like 5
years old it's a kind of nostalgia that
I think back then was you know nowadays
is seen there's kind of ugly but it's
like it feels like they cleaned it up
and made it very vibrant again uh well
when you do things as no Maj you are
taking the best yeah oh no like a lot of
people done this for a while like though
when eye balls
singing with some of the fantasies and
stuff but this one seems really immersed
in it
Oh a nice dog just like movies from the
70s or see old ads or see vintage 70
things it's like I mean we're saying oh
this is awesome but there was a lot of
shit oh yeah I mean there there are
color schemes and combinations that I
was like who thought this was a good
idea but this seems to be taking the
best of it which is a lot of fun but if
you were to tell me like the whole
climax of this is going to have this
peach color to it I say it sounds awful
that that sounds like would be
disgusting I look like mommy I look
terrible but they pull it off and they
really make it stand out for both the
line work and the various this is colors
a peach of any other way you can
describe its just groovy yeah I was just
watching the whole ending in like when
the color scheme was switching I mean it
just lets it go groovy
you know that's all I can say about it
um your point though earlier about like
well it starts off like this it doesn't
explain much what I still like this is a
kid how many cuz I watched the same
stuff you did how many cartoons when we
were kids in the 80s and through the
early 90s did we actually stand very
ever fucking see from the beginning I
can think of one not an odd thing maybe
to know I'm thinking nowadays though
because you know everything is immediate
access to kids and there's so much
available out really quick and they can
see this stuff from the beginning um we
have nieces and nephews and we have
friends with kids and let me tell you
something don't just watch any fucking
cartoon that's on they don't they're not
going to sitt ago both um from the
beginning no no no okay I know the show
gets more of like an epic feel as it
goes along and you know and it sounds
like they work out to it sourcing then
oh no it's not nothing is bad I'm saying
it's interesting that for a show that
wants to build up to this you know these
epic episodes they start off right in
the middle not explaining a great deal
like most traditional shows do I'm not
saying it's bad I'm saying that from a
marketing standpoint it's interesting
they would go that route and maybe
that's just the route other shows all I
would say is when I was growing up we
had this show called mysterious Cities
of Gold and it was fucking amazing
um did you follow the Sienese uncle yeah
um anyway sorry uh it it was a great
show and it was epic and it had a
complicated detailed story there was
some filler episodes but you were you
were watching a continual story I think
once I saw the first episode I didn't
ever saw the first ever I saw the first
episode and I do like this show two
years after I started watching it as a
kid like and even then I never knew how
it ended I still don't know how to end
and I'm gonna have to like torrent it or
something or go find it see if they're
selling it anywhere to figure it out
ended I still watched it and I still
watch it in reruns like it's not gonna
matter to a kid how with how it starts
you know you know they'll watch the more
thing about maybe the same thing with
the only one I can think of that we ever
watch from the beginning - we did catch
Batman the Animated Series ducktales
everyone and ducktales those are the
only jewelry confrim no no you know what
it may be that's exactly why they do it
they do it because they know when you
see a first episode it's gonna be oh
this is the first episode I know the
characters I don't need to blah blah
blah maybe they know it's like if you
catch it in the middle or feel like
you're catching it in the middle say oh
I got a catch up I got a watch there but
not only that what our first step but
think about duck tales think about all
of the cartoons we watch growing up what
are normally the first episode it's a
it's an exposition dump yeah it is a
giant plot dump and there is something I
appreciate about animes in that they
tend to dump you in the middle of the
story and then start feeding you
exposition over the course of that
episode but then the next few episodes
um and I think this one it helps because
we've learned one important thing a few
maybe important things but the only one
that was major is who his mother is
yeah you know and if you're a kid
watching this cartoon particularly in
will 15 minute like yeah snippets you
get more information fed to you as you
go on so it's more interesting to watch
successive episodes and going oh well
this is just a filler episode where you
know something that now maybe that will
happen I don't know because I'll end up
is a one planet no the funny thing is
actually and now
you mentioned and whenever I look back
at episodes I remember watching as a kid
when I saw you know usually I would
somehow see the first episode whatever
if you need to see but then was like
rewatch value the first episode I
usually skip now because I can tell
maybe that's Lister and it tells you
everything at once everything everything
you already know yeah so I think that's
part I generally think and I didn't
realize that shows even did this until I
started watching anime you know over 15
years ago like that this is another way
to do it and I appreciate it actually
generally speaking more than most
cartoon violence in America so I if
they're doing this now this is becoming
the new norm don't have a problem with
it yeah no I think just just a my
standpoint and I always think kids will
either since you speak what I clearly
don't it's a show that's a hit um but no
and so on that like you said has to do a
few more series and doesn't have the
best memory of this stuff that's the
only part that tries me belt about it
sucks for us yeah for us but as an
artistic way of doing it it's fine and
it's different because most of the time
if I'm watching a show I won't sit here
and freaked out about remembering things
I was going to the next step of see I
was like shit I gotta forget it if I
forget it I forget it I'll go look it up
online at some other point you know but
here it's a pain in the ass yeah so um
yeah I mean good start I me it's not
something like you know where it's like
genius but what what show starts off
with with that exactly you know very few
um so uh yep eager to get to the next
one and we will see you at that next one